which i think is another thing that's
interesting here there's been another
wonderful story
or a study based on people who say they
work 80
or more hours a week
and people are full of [ __ ] right
they they consider everything there was
one
example of like a ceo that said oh i'm
working like 90
hours a week and he was conf including
everything like um
going out to dinner like well i was
thinking about work uh okay
no that doesn't that's not what we're
talking about here i i tell people who
work for me that the average person in
our investment company puts in
i think 45 to 55 hours a week of that
probably 30 to 45 is in the office and
probably five is like
responding to emails or texts and stuff
like that off hours
i think a solid 50 um
and sometimes 60 is like the upper
bounds of not burning out that's where
i've come to in my career
is like yeah you know there are times
when things are competitive and you
you have to ratchet things up i've been
in those situations
but i think sustainability for me is
somewhere in that 50-hour week range
what do you think
a sustainable work schedule is
i mean obviously various by person but
let's just say in business you're in a
competitive environment you want to win
yeah i think what's also fascinating
about this is that we don't have to sort
of just grasp numbers out of
personal anecdotes yeah that this kind
of stuff has been studied
intensely as well and it's been codified
into these social
contracts that you we're gonna have
eight hours for work eight hours for
play
and eight hours for sleep that working a
40 hour work week
is actually a really uh well-designed
system and it wasn't designed out of
benevolence
like it was henry ford constructing the
model t
assembly line going you know what if i
make my workers work 50 hours a week or
60 hours a week they just end up making
more mistakes
putting parts in the wrong way and i
have to take essentially automobiles
that aren't working right back
and fix them and it costs more